join my day Joe Rogan podcast by night
all day January February March April May
June 6 months then the heavyweight
division needs them soft [ __ ] yeah John
Jones first heavyweight fight Brock
Lesnar ba-ba-ba-ba you're welcome
bum-bum-bum-bum-bum
yeah imagine that fight the only problem
is dumb did you think so yes
big Merkel min the grappling I think
you're just completely diving [ __ ]
steel big wood [ __ ] rat him you do
this nasty baby og you pissed that
multi-ball from Cleveland and he'll [ __ ]
Rock left cuz oh say it you better do
the [ __ ] steroids
yo pic is crazy me I love that
[ __ ] yo chick I love them I love
them to immigrant mentality
bring them on bro bro market out give
him more [ __ ] steroids what's that
you another word America yeah whatever
the [ __ ] he yes with his dubs Mayo chick
definitely Bordelaise in Cleveland Ohio
the ones got that [ __ ] crazy blood in
him and he don't give a [ __ ] away he's
proved to listen he proved it went with
[ __ ] over een really don't give a [ __ ]
put him in there unless god I gave the
Bronco parked my car at all ya got to
loose to the Gil [ __ ] brocklander just
ragdoll pull more pull poor mom are
[ __ ] yeah but Marc hunts never been
the kind of grandmas deep is just a pain
yeah
oh no I think Steve baby and you know
watched if he punches deeper in the face
it's gonna get more steam out of his
[ __ ] ears and you saw it Steve's not
bring we won't leave last night coming
back but unless they never call he's not
gonna come back and fight for a world
title right away no consignment no TV
always the biggest embarrassment of
Laura oh you're crazy
oh the biggest [ __ ] embarrassment of
the year that why would that be
embarrassment was embarrassing just
embarrassing him against Mark Hunt they
knew he was on the juice he went in
there loaded to the gills it was just an
embattled Joey it was an embarrassing
thing for everybody and Mark Hunt out
every [ __ ] right to be mad they put
him in there with a guy that's coming
off rocket [ __ ] fuel that dude don't
just only d-ball look at the size of his
[ __ ] head he's taking [ __ ] that makes
your [ __ ] head grow doctor that guy's
a [ __ ] pit bulls I hope they put him
against my Oh chick I will fly the
[ __ ] clean rag dumbest climate con
climbing a mountain so sassy
I found this not my nose I was bigger
than his gum da Dada I take the gum out
to eat it anyway yeah I was so long it
was like a coke book I got a flashback
from the east sky and hail that
[ __ ] anyway did you need a
booger cuz I love them I love them from
time to time I have a little squeeze it
just comes out around no notes and it's
got like a little clam so it's all bored
with you with all this Steve knows [ __ ]
anyway no boogers listen from time to
time
oh when you eat when you could quote for
30 years to have it you wake up in the
morning pick one out it's like she came
in Coke Gossage you inhale that
[ __ ] it's like going to the
dentist for free I will throw up on this
[ __ ] table this is very nice do you
ever do feel like there's a tummy while
you're eating boogers not to be honest
with ourselves
we're all friends here that was the most
embarrassing [ __ ] thing I've ever
seen I agree they knew he was on it and
they put that [ __ ] animal in there
okay and you know what man go ahead keep
doing those steroids put him in against
be open
whatever oh [ __ ] she loved that
Cleveland [ __ ] dude IPE just got
Hilde kilims you'll [ __ ] kill him in
general stupid I don't think they would
ever be able to have him come off a
suspension and fight for the title
that's not how it goes
ah no four billion dollars though either
scab well for Iranians head right now
billion dollars right now that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that long we lost Ron you can come
out of your mouth you drive me crazy
yeah they lost Ronda and the only other
thing we got is [ __ ] Khan and he's
having a baby you don't want to [ __ ]
come back no you know you talking about
he might come back right now well it was
my bed yeah but I don't want to give him
we supposed to fight who's he supposed
to be supposed to fight that [ __ ]
collar beep and happy gory end of story
gonna be no more [ __ ] around that
nobody on let's do it let's set it up no
that's not enough I am with Joey let's
go good look at this [ __ ] you don't need
to fight out though you don't need to
fight nobody he's number one right or is
it was your boy number one Tony Cadiz
number one ok then that's the fight
enough everybody hey wait a minute Tony
was number one and then khabib Kim
became number one why did could be a
bleep frog Tony I don't who knows the
ring because he talked Oh Stu should
really but he's only fought a couple
time
go fast brother khabees number one well
that's the thing he did listen he's
fighting now he's available today he's
available today he's available for
Brooklyn okay he said it when he fought
onions Michael Johnson he's available
for final running ok he's available for
Brooklyn inch let's get Eddie against
Rafael that's a good fight let's get
Edson back in there people like watching
him live reef let's get everybody else's
reaction there let's get we got some
[ __ ] people here oh yeah a lot of
good guys we got a lot of everyone car
they was excited let's get here
he's south pay-per-view bounce around
gnarly not three hundred thousand but
he's he's always playing on 170 Robbie
Lawler that guy that is good [ __ ]
they got Joey not to be the match made a
[ __ ] got it okay
well no he'd yeah man it's an
interesting situation I got nothing a
good [ __ ] if I got ahold yeah yellow
want to give us the fight right water
see no there's not a problem
we don't they won I want a higher
caliber that's the vibe eat it end the
story
there's no Alto okay no Tony Ferguson
there's no babies there's no not that he
has a booby but he's got a peeper it's
also nothing awful
it's not a big job for me Joe look it's
a lady's a little 20 million on you the
baby's weight six weeks but Connors
already got 20 million that's the
difference does he want to take tonight
you can took birth of his his life is
more important than what the UFC my boys
here on the show I agree with you Brenda
and may 5th made with labor the Memorial
Day weekend
collar beeping him Habib happy Ferguson
beeps yes Ferguson says I mean I'll be a
Beebe North America since you're wrong
let's have some fun
your Ferguson sarong let's have some
[ __ ] fun it's a father owned is now
fighting 55 again I didn't say that but
we're all mixing wrong mixing weights
right now did we not say that before no
I want to put out door against could be
but know how all those thinking about
moving up any moving up anyway so who
gives a [ __ ] it seems like he's kind of
chasing like a chess move yes you she's
on her once that Connor if he wants that
fight let's that's what everybody wants
to see again
whatever the [ __ ] order is but the
order that they're trying to put
together is the order I don't want to
see because they have to sell paper but
no no they're gonna do this okay this is
the route you [ __ ]
miss Ellen is there gonna deal with
uncle Joey they're gonna bring him back
against [ __ ] the black dude at 170
that's the fight here in Woodleigh
that's already been made at the thing
way he's gonna come together all that
[ __ ] down
watch it watch it but we just said that
would Lee's gonna fight Pittsburgh I
catch what I know I know I know that's
all great they're gonna fight watch you
think that tyron woodley is gonna fight
her own will that was already
established from New York
Tyron Woodley hiren time tyron woodley
is already gonna [ __ ] fight them okay
that's the first fight then they're
gonna try that that's the fight they're
gonna put their 170 maybe in May what
happens it could be then this is what
she's using these are the ones this is
my decision
this isn't my decision this is beyond
you this is beyond me how do you know
this and I already seen the setup at the
[ __ ] you knew you artwork were you
[ __ ] blind because you didn't see
what I see I talked to them I know you
talked to them but did I tell you the
deck that I'm talking to the people
don't know this again so you didn't know
that's right owns it I did I love that
understand but the problem is here that
that was the seed was already planted in
New York it was already planted none of
you mother [ __ ] saw it what do you
guys watch what seed the seed of him
talking back and forth with Tyrone Tyrod
it's he died only okay that's the
[ __ ] shade Jesus Christ that's the
[ __ ] seat smells like a zoo he's
gonna love it
he's gonna [ __ ] me he's gonna look at
something you already at the press
colonies ed oh he doesn't fight enough
okay wait what's going on here that's
good time at Wayne's talking [ __ ] that's
the seed you dumb [ __ ] that what is
happening here what is he saying he's
just talking [ __ ] so he hear what he
said
I don't think something went on they're
just gone which condition come on send
somebody to say hey come out come on
that came up don't like you're lucky I
don't come to seven years long walk you
can do it look at them trying to be cute
with owns a moment here there's a moment
see hey bro going between Tyron Woodley
and
yeah there it got set up right there on
each other down okay so that the next
[ __ ] fight it's kind of saying we can
do it at 70 we can do Jolie's I wanna
[ __ ] you people don't see dick because
you see what you wanna [ __ ] see
that's the next fight they're ready he
already planted the [ __ ] seed he's
not gonna fight Tyrese gonna fight
tyronn and killed more time for kala
babe like they drew Dennis ebradham when
Frankie idea was [ __ ] lurking they
threw dennis siver more than anything is
available then asifa's available it's
you know look at all the color of his
skin so now how red he gets he's talking
some truth it's in between [ __ ] he's
he doesn't want to fight Ferguson he's
drunk gonna fight Tony Perkis why not
it's nip just bro it's too much height
and Tony Ferguson don't give a [ __ ] he's
a monster back stage again [ __ ]
farted there's a horrible telling me
it's only just a message it's a
tremendous Ferrell sikozu oh look at
this they are go ahead [ __ ] please guys
get some volume on that we get volume on
that what back there I hear this go all
the way back way back here we go
crank it up he's setting it up she's
setting up for one Sharpie belt
Oh see there's eight guys that guys
yourselves like a woman with that phone
whoa the helix crazy is gone about
missed ten guys my right look how drain
Tyron looks yeah it's here let's ever
wondered again what we wanna we wanna
shh shh
what's up we need your assistance
you hear that lady - I said what's up
any staircar i said what's up he said
not much but meanwhile you look at
tyrunt tyrunt looks so drain there when
he made that wait it's like right after
you made the way I'll do it's crazy I
was an officer in that fight
he's only go for three [ __ ] god damn
only nobody ever saw this [ __ ] he
doesn't want he's not gonna fight
Ferguson
because it's a [ __ ] it's a Aerosmith
Guns & Roses was Aerosmith on steroids
and Tony Ferguson is little Diaz with
[ __ ] out blood in them you understand
me he don't wanna you don't want Tony
Ferguson and Dana it's not a job in
Jungle John Uncle Bobby Dana is not
gonna let isn't his nephew fight I'll be
okay getting Conor versus Tony is not a
draw it's not a job for Conor I know
he's your guy that's a big [ __ ] fight
make totally all right that's it even
Soul Reaper this could be a [ __ ] fun
I don't why didn't you think they're
making it Eddie you tell me why do you
think they make it it's not gonna sell
and I love these guys don't give me I'm
not I'm not clowning your guy but as far
as the average consumer buying a
pay-per-view that's not a sell it's just
not hell yeah it is I just gotta
fighting any money sale deciding a top
challenger is always a sale until
comment but Tony Fergus is most
certainly a top challenger when Nate
Diaz fought Conor for the first time was
a giant fight because Nate Diaz had a
name and he's a bit he's a bigger name
than Tony arguably for sure
not even close much bigger now after he
beat afford the Diaz brothers and Tony
wasn't the same as it is rather it's a
different news whether it's a different
thing now but but he had it because of
Nick and Nick had had all the
Strikeforce
success Elite XC success you know all
that is a lot of TV time there's the
Ultimate Fighter winner Nate and then on
top of that Nick had just got done
beating Anderson or fighting Anderson
rather and you know Nick Nick is like a
pretty well-known figure right these
brother they're both the Diaz brothers
are like so that's a different level but
having them take that fight on short
notice to
but Connor was the main draws my point
congressman Donovan idea but this isn't
because I agree it's he's the main draw
if you're calling you're his manager he
going let's fight Tony who's a tough
[ __ ] matchup but he's not as big as
the name as a guy like Nate Diaz at 55
who we're gonna make more money maybe
not as tough as a fight bigger name so
they're doing it from a business point
and he's not fighting you I'm not
fighting could be you also have to fight
in a normal fight for they're gonna do a
Russia card and when they do a Russia
card they want to do a rush card with
Conor or with heavy rather so when they
do a Russia card with Habib it's most
likely gonna be for a title I would
imagine so no time it all depends if
Connor accepts it remember another house
on all the Pete Tony and in my current
interim and apparently they offered it
to Tony and Tony said that you want to
make the same amount of money that Habib
makes which is perfectly funds first
fine
but you know they said nope you got a
contract you gotta honor your contract
that's at least how it's been explained
yes that's that's being explaining to go
no well you sign these contracts you
gotta honor the contract yeah but that
that that only works one way the only
works for the UFC because they don't
honor all the contracts do they write me
if it works but they can cut them
digging you have a six like contract
right lost too but that seems gonna cut
it's in the contract that you can get
cut if it wasn't in the contract there's
guys who fought and they fought out
their entire contract for sure right I'm
just saying Pedro hit once remember in
the early days and Pedro his I had this
giant contract because they thought the
Pedro is gonna be the heavyweight champ
and so they were giving him like
undercard fight so he's making quarter
of a million dollars yeah yeah it's
tricky man because I get the idea that
they would want to protect Conor um you
know and really set up the big-money
fights especially now cuz he's the
biggest guy but then you got Connor
who's kind of [ __ ] crazy and like what
the way he does of John down Tyrone I
don't think it's Connor doing I think
it's from from a business standpoint
they're going what's the biggest fight
pot let's say you have three fights left
who are the three biggest names we can
fight and to make this happen so I stay
on the field big and make the most money
he might not be on defeat and he's
definitely not undefeated now right but
the biggest thing is the Woodley fight
because that's a 17.7 that's a third
bout guys that's a fight and you didn't
say your shave on much control Eamon you
mother
as if you didn't see it number two
listen I'm not saying the khabib is
gonna be Connor
especially after I don't like to take
the punch on Michael Connor I'm not
saying Michaels Michael Johnson but the
fight is could be and then the next
fight has to be Ferguson if he beats him
that's the way it is when I cook
Ferguson to me can't wait they can't
wait like Ferguson needs a fight like in
the next four or five months
Kabhi needs a fight in the next [ __ ]
two three months I don't fight in
Brooklyn and don't you forgot my
daughter from now - he said Kenya when
you went to view them yeah he put the
hat on you understand he said you'll
fight and Brooke put a hat on my head
every time and every time right now it's
great I [ __ ] love wearing that and
you don't say no you say he looks again
shows me that I give him the knife yeah
put that on like that hat any news me as
a fan
all I see is Tony verse could be that's
that's the fight there's not a better
matchup I can be made anew I don't know
about that
I like Tony versus Connor I even like a
B versus Connor
yeah I like it I like Connor versus
Woodley I like that fight too
that's why thank you that's the next
money fight but he's gonna eventually I
don't think yes he gives us enough power
to do that I dig you bragging you ever
get that much control power
yeah he's got a little power well here's
the thing about you window yourself
Howard Lee loses two Bisping if he loses
catchweight fight he still keeps that
$170 drop that's if that catch wait I
doubt that that's just beautiful mighty
right what no you can't hold on to
division I run against my boy I gotta go
Joey I'm telling you this plan was that
going after Tyler they planted the seed
right there good when you can't tie it
to divisions backstage of you lose all
the guys exactly what happen I do don't
go away from the Russian and horses as
long as they can mean but specifically
do what we have each other no they'll do
the NASA thing when they go to interview
him they die in car accidents and [ __ ]
but that's the fight guys that's the
fight right there that everybody wants
to see right off the bat I'd love to see
Connor and could be my love to see
Ferguson and khabib but then I'm gonna
do that
they're gonna hope that they fall off a
cliff from a plane goes down let's give
him the money fine which is 170 can he
get the third belt here's nothing can
you lose if he does lose if he goes up
to nothing he's tiring nothing happens
yeah that's risk-free same thing with
that Nate first Nate Diaz okay remember
who runs this [ __ ] right you do it what
you do what do you do a toning could be
they go to Bellator hell no they can hit
this off god they're gonna say [ __ ] you
UFC we can't take this no more hiding it
from us
[Music]